you know when kobut first started i used
to say to john let's go to the
winchester
have a nice cold pint and wait for all
this to blow over
and at some point in there we'll kill my
stepdad yeah yeah
too bad kovid's still going on and we
got a comic on it at home but we got a
nick frost and simon peg show apparently
truth seekers for amazon prime let's see
what's in store today
it's always exciting when they're
together can you feel it
ancient magic resides
all around us ours is not the only
universe
there are realms beyond it underneath it
a myriad of parallel dimensions
hey did you see one of my digestives no
no way yeah
[Music]
a gateway between worlds
i'll see you on the other side
[Applause]
careful
[Music]
cool yeah
it was very very little simon pagan
that wasn't exclusively a nick brock i
mean it looks like he's the star of the
show
this looks pretty cool that's a solid
teaser yeah that's like an
actual teaser trailer right there
a lot of times i say teaser and it's a
full on one but this is a solid tease
yeah it's just a medley of uh little
action items and then the tone of the
show the humor and all that i mean
i liked the idea of the visuals that
they showed us because part of me is
thinking like oh
it's going to be like an x-files or a
supernatural or something like that and
i'm sure that it's going to owe
something to that but just the
extent of like the out-there stuff with
like cult-looking things that they're
showing us and like ghosts and
apparitions
it somehow made itself look different
from those shows even though
you know the premise itself kind of
seems similar i've been watching
shows like doom patrol and umbrella
academy recently so i'm all
for like the weird zany fully
out there cerebral trippy horror comedy
like those are the kind of shows that
i'm really like eating up right now this
is exciting because this is also the
the strange kind of comedy genre that
people like nick frost and simon
pegg excel in that they've become
beloved for being a part of and
it's like yeah simon pegg is barely in
this trailer just typed in the imdb to
find out
nick frost and simon pegg they were two
of the four main writers for this show
so to have their
creative input there as well you know
dealing with
horror sci-fi this is like uh a forum
for us in a way nostalgia based
you know like from what i actually did
what was the show they did with edgar
wright back in the day
oh spaced yeah yeah haven't seen space
have you yeah
space is a lot of fun you can definitely
see the early traces of all their film
style as well as their sensibility in
terms of references and the dry width
yeah yeah this is about what i'd expect
like this looks like an amazon prime
show would you say
even if you're just saying nick frost is
starring in something this is almost
exactly what i'd expect and i guess
that's kind of the one thing that's
missing on some impact
is this is a hundred percent like yeah
that's about it
you know if anything what excites me is
malcolm mcdowell yeah
you know i mean it's funny because yeah
i feel similarly but i guess i'm just
more excited by that because it's been a
long time since the last cornetto movie
it does look kind of like what you would
want slash expect from them doing a
series with this kind of flavor i get
why that would be kind of underwhelming
there's not like a surprise there but
for me i'm kind of just happy to have
the flavor back
well it's a teaser trailer i bet that
what'll separate this from what we've
seen from not just the cordetto trilogy
but how they were together in paul
um and other various works like they've
gone and done things apart that are both
in the sci-fi or horror comedy category
simon pegg especially what always
surprises
wait i mean unless you're like a real
fan i don't think it's really a surprise
you kind of expect it to be in their
films but i think with the character
exploration more than just the horror
and the comedy i think the character
exploration and watching all that really
come to life and i think amazon prime
especially with the original series they
have at least the ones that are the most
you know touted i feel like it'll
truly deliver on giving us something
different than what we've come to see
from them in the past
not just more of the same i think right
now this is like getting us like oh yeah
this is this is what i come to expect
from these guys but i feel like there's
going to be some
pleasant surprises in here and if you're
going to tell me like ghost hunter
supernatural hunter
type of stories this is the kind of team
i'd want to see
pull off for a show if you look at the
amount of humor that they derive out of
film style and technique and also out of
character and also the heavy amount of
heart and drama they draw in that
character i'm really excited to see that
translate into the tv setting because
you know you can lump those films
especially the cornetto films in as just
like oh yeah they're comedies but when
you go back and look at them they're so
crafted on the filmmaking side and a lot
of that has to do with edgar wright but
i'm excited because both simon pagan and
nick frost you know they both have those
writing chops as well they have
co-writing credits on those movies and
things yeah just looking forward to
seeing that expanded because it could be
just as touching as
it is funny all right guys well truth
seekers you're gonna be prioritizing
this show if you like john will you guys
can uh subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell and hey
let's see what else comes out soon
you